Technology has done a lot of great things
for humanity, and has succeeded in making
the world feel a little more connected.
But some people argue that the use of CGI
on the silver screen has gotten out of control.
Luckily for them, there are filmmakers out
there who still insist on doing things the
old fashioned way.
These are 10 Amazing Movie Effects Created
Without Computers.
Terminator 2: Judgement Day
Of all the big screen cybernetic organisms,
Arnold Schwarzenegger’s T-800 is probably
the most iconic.
Known commonly as a Terminator, the machine
has been terrorizing audiences since 1984.
And while there are technically a bunch of
films in the franchise, 1991’s Terminator
2: Judgement Day is the absolute best.
A lot of the effects were created using a
combination of CGI and manual efforts on-set,
but one of the movie’s best gags actually
ended up on the cutting room floor.
During a scene where Sarah (Linda Hamilton)
and John (Edward Furlong) are resetting the
Terminator’s CPU, director James Cameron
utilized clever camera placement, a body double,
and Linda Hamilton’s twin sister to create
the illusion that the procedure was all happening
in a mirror.
Apollo 13
Okay seriously.
Tom Hanks gets to do all the fun stuff.
And after years of paying his Hollywood dues,
we think he’s earned it.
One of the actor’s most iconic roles in
Apollo 13 is no exception.
After their craft is damaged, the astronauts
onboard try desperately to get safely back
to earth.
NASA plays a large part in the film, but it
turns out they were also instrumental behind
the scenes, too.
To get the zero-gravity environment just right,
the association lent the production a plane.
Flying in parabolic arcs, anyone onboard experienced
intervals of real weightlessness, and they
didn’t even have to leave the atmosphere.
Casino Royale
Casino Royale introduced the world to a shiny
new Bond.
Daniel Craig had a well-tailored tuxedo to
fill, and he did it in a big way.
Of course with every new Bond movie comes
a host of new toys for the character to destroy.
While some of the situations are wildly exaggerated,
there is one moment that is 100% authentic.
It wouldn’t be a Bond movie if the character
didn’t destroy his brand new car, and Casino
Royale is no different.
Rather than using CGI to simulate a crash,
a real driver was behind the wheel during
a scene when the Aston Martin flips multiple
times.
The team even used an air cannon to help the
vehicle flip a few extra times.
The Dark Knight
This may be Christopher Nolan’s first appearance
on this list, but it won’t be his last.
The director has been applauded for his practical
filmmaking methods, and seems to be deterred
by nothing.
No stunt is impossible.
So when it came time for Batman to chase the
Joker through the streets of Gotham, the team
wrapped up the sequence with a big finish.
That semi-flip you just saw?
100% real.
Stunt driver Jim Wilkey flipped the vehicle
in the middle of a real street, surrounded
by real buildings.
At it’s height, the trailer was over fifty
feet in the air.
And thankfully, they only had to do it once.
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
After making his mark as a funnyman, Jim Carrey
picked up a few serious roles and showed the
world he wasn’t just a one trick pony.
So if you’re expecting his usual comedic
flavor, then the movie Eternal Sunshine of
the Spotless Mind is not for you.
The movie toys with the notion of memory.
And one sequence chronicles how it feels to
have one dream quickly transition into another.
While a scene like this almost begs for the
use of CGI, director Michael Gondry rejected
the idea.
What was happening off-screen was almost as
interesting as what was on it.
Because both Carrey and co-star Kate Winslet
were running from set to set, and trying to
beat the camera.
Old school!
2001: A Space Odyssey
Stanley Kubrick is one of the most celebrated
and subversive filmmakers of all time.
His movies may be divisive, but there’s
no denying how visually stunning they are.
From A Clockwork Orange to The Shining, the
director has left a permanent mark on cinema.
But when film school students get together
to talk shop, they always come back to 2001:
A Space Odyssey.
A movie that was revolutionary for its time,
Odyssey utilized several techniques that wouldn’t
be fully developed until years later.
And Kubrick noticed that rotating the set
around a fixed camera created a pretty cool
effect.
One that was used over and over after the
movie’s release.
Inception
Christopher Nolan is back.
And this time, he’s breaking one of the
earth’s oldest laws: gravity.
Each dream world has it’s own beautiful
aesthetic.
But when the drop kicks in on level two, everything
in the environment becomes weightless.
Audiences watch as Joseph Gordon Levitt scrambles
to secure the team, and gets in a pretty cool
fight along the way.
Filmmakers built the entire set encased in
a grouping of eight rings, which rotated as
the camera stayed fixed.
“But wait!” we hear you cry, “didn’t
Kubrick do the exact same thing in 2001: A
Space Odyssey?”
The answer is yes, but Kubrick didn’t make
it look THIS good.
Jurassic Park
In the earlier half of his career, Steven
Spielberg had a thing for animatronics.
It’s becoming increasingly rare to see mechanical
creatures on set.
They can stop functioning, break, and cause
a collective migraine for everyone involved.
Case in point: Jurassic Park’s tyrannosaurus
rex.
The dinosaur was made by Stan Winston’s
studio, and was fully mechanical.
You don’t have to be a mechanic to understand
that rain plus robot equals disaster.
As a result, the giant dino would randomly
turn itself on and roar at the crew.
Which, understandably, scared the shit out
of anyone nearby.
The Lord of the Rings
Perspective is an interesting thing.
And is the reason a skilled filmmaker like
Peter Jackson can manipulate your eyes into
believing adults are hobbit-sized.
While the films give audiences a lot to look
at, the biggest trick is right in front of
your face.
Using specially engineered set pieces and
clever camera placement, the director created
the illusion that the Hobbits are physically
smaller than everyone else.
If that seems like a lot of unnecessary work,
consider that using CGI to shrink the actors
in every frame would be even more tedious.
The Dark Knight Rises
You know what?
Christopher Nolan is a modern filmmaker with
old school sensibilities, and we can’t help
it if he’s responsible for multiple legendary
non-CG stunts, okay?
In the final film in his Batman trilogy, big
bad Bane executes a heist that results in
a plane dropping from the sky.
After hearing what we’ve already told you,
you might not be surprised to find out that
Nolan really did make a plane drop from the
sky.
On top of that, he did it quickly.
And a shot that was supposed to take five
days was delivered in two.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other awesome non-CGI movie
effects?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.